democrats roll out the cast of hamilton
the foe emotion of kamala harris and
angry joe biden to remind americans that
january 6th was the inflection point for
humanity i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
i protect my data with a vpn so should
you visit expressvpn.com
ben speaking of which using the internet
without expressvpn well you can see i'm
traveling it's like checking in your
baggage at the airport without any sort
of lock you think that your stuff is
private but then somebody starts rifling
through your underwear well when you go
online without a vpn that's what
everybody is doing with your personal
data particularly your internet service
provider which can see every single
website you visit they can then legally
sell that information without your
consent to add companies and text giants
who then use your data to target you
when you use expressvpn isps can no
longer see that sort of online activity
your identity is anonymized by a secure
vpn server your data is also encrypted
for maximum protection which is the
reason that i use expressvpn also
because it's super easy to use all i
have to do is open up the app hit one
button and now it's fired up and i am
protected it works on all your devices
phones laptops even routers so everyone
who shares your wi-fi can be protected
i've got too much personal data on my
computer to just be handing that over to
my isp secure your online activity today
by visiting expressvpn.com
ben today that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
ben you can get an extra three months
for free expressvpn.com
ben to get started alrighty so yesterday
was the most important day in american
history it was the first anniversary of
january 6th and it was like christmas in
january
for the democrats they couldn't really
determine whether it was supposed to be
a solemn commemoration or a celebration
or what exactly it was supposed to be
they just knew it was really really
important and the reason it was really
important is because joe biden's poll
numbers are in the toilet and the only
reason that joe biden was elected in
2020 to begin with
is because there were a lot of people
who did not like donald trump and so joe
biden ran on i'm gonna restore the soul
of this country
and people are like okay that sounds all
right and then he immediately got into
office and started pursuing bernie
sanders agenda and his entire popularity
which had been close to 60 is now all
the way down to 40 so he's trying to
revive his flagging presidency by going
back to january 6th and just whipping
that dead horse as much as he possibly
can and you can tell
how much the democrats are reliant on
january 6 how much they see it as a
political opportunity
you can see that by how they treated it
it was sort of how they treated you
remember there was a senator named paul
wellstone from minnesota this is i don't
know now 15 20 years ago and he died in
a plane crash and there was a big
democratic event
for him a memorial event and instead of
it being a unifying event involving
members of both sides of the political
aisle instead democrats just went to
paul wellstone's funeral and proceeded
to basically throw a political rally
well this is pretty much what they did
yesterday on january 6. and here's the
dead giveaway
nancy pelosi literally had the cast of
hamilton sing a song in the middle of
the january 6th quote-unquote memorial
okay first of all the january 6 memorial
normally when you have some sort of
commemorative memorial it's because a
lot of people died right typically you
have a 9 11 memorial because 3 000
americans were killed we have a december
7th 1941 memorial because 2 300
americans were killed typically when you
have a memorial it's because there was
tremendous human suffering involved the
grand total number of people who were
killed not not people who died of
associated heart attack or or being
crushed by a crowd or or died later then
the number of people who are actively
killed on january 6 is one and it was
ashley babbitt who was shot by a capital
police officer while trying to
move through a broken window to get a
congress people
and so they have this big memorial event
and here's nancy pelosi introducing the
cast of hamilton for a for a number
is there anything more in the bubble
than this
first of all the people who desperately
love hamilton they all live in blue
states that is not a there's not a huge
crowd for hamilton in the red states i'm
not even ripping on the musical right
now although it's not my favorite
musical for a variety of reasons but
the the the people who are just obsessed
with it they are all people who are kind
of
theater majors
living in blue states
so where is the broad popular appeal it
reminds me of 2016 when hillary clinton
was running for president and at the
democratic national convention they
brought forth all of these pop stars to
speak precisely to their base but to no
one else here's nancy pelosi yesterday
introducing the cast of hamilton for
some odd reason
i have no idea what this has to do with
january 6th but here we go
we're privileged to have a contribution
from one of the great creative talents
of our time
lin manuel
miranda
may his beautiful words be an
inspiration to us
among the words he said and in the music
we'll make it right for you
if we lay a strong enough foundation
will pass it on to you
and will give the world to you what in
the world
really i'm supposed to take these people
seriously really how am i supposed to
take these people seriously
i mean this would be the equivalent of
republicans holding some sort of
commemoration for the blm riot of 2020
and then bringing out lee greenwood to
sing god bless the usa right like th
this is this is the kind of stuff that
the democrats listen to in the shower
but i'm not sure
what it has to do with january 6th per
se but that's because it's all a big
show that's all this is it's just a big
show so the first person they brought
out was kamala harris i don't know why
they keep bringing forth commemoral
harris to speak at these sorts of things
i i really don't she is absolutely awful
at this it is extraordinary how bad she
is at this kamala harris the vice
president of the united states and
normally you might assume a baseline
level of competence for somebody like
kamala harris after all she has been an
attorney general of major stage who's
elected senator from a major state and
now she's vice president but here is the
thing nope
i'm not sure i've ever seen anyone in
american politics fail upward the way
that kamala harris has failed upward i
mean to the point where the
administration knows she's so bad that
they're like well maybe we should fail
her upward to the supreme court just to
get rid of her
you know how much people hate you when
they're talking about elevating you to
the supreme court just to get rid of you
like we'll do anything to get rid of
this lady make her god emperor i don't
care just get her the hell out of here
anyway kamala harris spoke yesterday at
the capitol building and was predictably
awful we'll get to that in just one
moment first let's talk about a simple
fact if you run a business you need to
solve your hr issues right you think
that the hr issues are a big nothing or
you don't have to think about them and
it's toby from the office but here's the
thing if hr is not handled there's so
many issues that can come back and bite
you directly on the tokens wrongful
termination suits minimum wage
requirements labor regulations hr
manager salaries are not cheap they're
an average of 70 000 bucks a year bambi
it's spelled b-a-m-e-e it was created
specifically for small business you can
get a dedicated hr manager craft hr
policy and maintain your compliance all
for just 99 bucks a month with bambi you
can change hr from your biggest
liability to your biggest strength your
dedicated hr manager is available by
phone email or real-time chat from
onboarding determinations they customize
your policies to fit your business and
help you manage your employees
day-to-day all for just 99 bucks a month
they're month-to-month no hidden fees
you can cancel anytime you start your
business because you wanted to spend
time on hr compliance let bambi help you
today go to bambi.com shapiro right now
to schedule that free hr audit that is
bambi.com shapiro
b-a-m-b-e-e dot com
shapiro okay so here we go with the most
incompetent vice president of my
lifetime i mean it is not
would it be fair to say ever i think
it'd be fair to say ever it's like spiro
agnew or her right there there are not a
lot of contenders here
on on this on this
short list of bad vice presidents here's
kamala harris speaking from the capital
rotunda because of course this was the
most important inflection point in
american history so we have to do
exactly what democrats say we have to do
comparing january 6th to some of the
worst days in american history
certain dates echo throughout history
including dates
that instantly
remind all who have lived through them
where they were
and what they were doing
when our democracy came under assault
dates that occupy
not only a place on our calendars
but a place in our collective memory
december 7 1941
september 11
and january 6
2021 um
no
no i don't think that 20 years from now
if somebody asks what were you doing on
january 6 2021 everyone's like i know
exactly where i was
in fact if you asked me what i was doing
on january 6 2021 i was watching tv and
watching some of it happen but i don't
actively remember where i was i might i
think i was at the office for part of
the day but i don't remember if you
asked me exactly what happened when i
heard about september 11th i can tell
you exactly to the moment where i was
when i heard about september 11th
uh this is this one is not on that list
beyond that
are you really comparing a day on which
a couple of hundred idiots went into the
capitol building some of them with
violent intent some of them just kind of
wandering in
are you really comparing that
a riot in which
one person total
was killed like by the
in the rye one person was actually
killed in the riot are you comparing
that to
december 7th 1941 which not only ended
with the death of 2 300 american service
members but also began america's
involvement in world war ii which led to
hundreds of thousands of deaths or
september 11 2001 which was the
terrorist murder of 3 000 americans the
destruction of the twin towers in new
york city the attack on the pentagon
the taking down of a plane in
shanksville pennsylvania
and the initiation of the war on terror
which involved two major american wars
in two different theaters is that is
that what we are comparing january 6th
to now because just on the calendar that
was not
probably among the 10 most damaging
riots of the last year
and probably there were 10 more damaging
riots during 2020 than there were
january 6th there's 1.5 million dollars
in damage done total to the capitol
building on january 6th and one person
who was killed there's some 25 people
who died in the black lives matter riots
of 2020 and five billion dollars in
uninsured property damage and about two
billion dollars in insured property
damage done during that period so
no
okay but what this is really about is
that we have to strengthen the rule of
law strengthen the rule of democracy now
this is really galling stuff to hear
from some of the exact same people who
were literally attempting to bail out
rioters in 2020 people who had built a
narrative i know everybody forgets about
this stuff but leading up to the
election of 2020 it was not just
president trump who was suggesting that
the election was going to be corrupt and
there are going to be problems it was
democrats who are suggesting this also
you'll recall that lewis de joy was the
postmaster general right the guy who's
in charge of the post office he was
accused of actively removing mailboxes
to prevent people from sending in their
absentee ballots
this is like a big controversy and the
groundwork had been laid that if trump
had won again the democrats would have
claimed that that was illegitimate
because there were riots in 2017 when
trump was inaugurated on inauguration
day 200 people were arrested in 2017. i
know we're supposed to pretend that
didn't happen it did people were burning
cars in the middle of washington dc in
2017.
people tried to occupy the steps of the
capitol building like some of some of
the members of the women's march
but but here is como harris suddenly in
favor of the rule of law
honestly it is the hypocrisy here that
is so calling some of us have said that
all law breakers should go to prison
some of us have said that only
lawbreakers on their side should go to
prison if you're one of the latter you
don't get to talk about rule of law you
don't but that's exactly what kamal
harris does
you see the strength of democracy
is the rule of law
the strength of democracy is the
principle
that everyone should be treated equally
that elections
should be free and fair
that corruption
should be given no quarter
the strength of democracy
is that it empowers
the people i'm sorry when you say the
strength of democracy is the principle
that everybody should be treated equally
and your entire administration is built
on the principle not of equality of
rights but equity which is a suggestion
that there ought to be equality of
outcome and that any disparity in
american life you can chalk up to the
failures of our institutions
like it's hard for me to buy that we can
all come together around a set of
principles when i know on a fundamental
level you do not believe in those
principles i'm perfectly happy to say
and have said many many times don't lie
about elections accept election results
you should not break the law if you
violate the laws you go to jail right
this applies across the board but the
fact that i'm saying it applies across
the board makes people on the left mad
if i say it applies across the board
like well you're doing what about ism
it's not what about ism to say that
something should apply equally it's what
about ism for you guys to say that it
shouldn't apply to your side it should
only apply to the other side
and here's the point from kamala harris
and she's so obvious she's so bad at
this my god she's bad at this
there's a tremendous lack of subtlety
i don't know whether it is just because
she's not particularly smart or whether
it's because she thinks she's smarter
than she is but whatever it is
kamala harris then comes out and she
says exactly what she wants which is
give me more power i want more power and
then somehow she botches the
constitution of the united states she
tries to recite it word for word it does
not go well
let's be clear
we must pass
voting rights bills that are now before
the senate
and
the american people
must also do something more
we cannot sit on the sidelines
we must unite
in defense
of our democracy
in order to form a more perfect union
establish justice
ensure
domestic tranquility
provide for the common
defense promote
the general welfare
and secure
the blessings of liberty
to ourselves
and to our prosperity and prosperity
okay so at the very end my favorite part
of this is that all she's doing here is
just reading the constitution like a bad
third grade candidate for secretary for
class secretary that's what she's doing
right there she gets to the end of that
and she's like we have to pass
everything i want you to pass and now
i'm just going to read you the preamble
to the constitution of the united states
except i'm going to completely blow it
we're not securing the blessings of
prosperity to ourselves at the end of
the constitution that's not a thing it's
posterity she corrects herself and she
almost starts laughing at herself
because she knows that she's blown it
okay that was all preamble to president
biden so kamala harris's stick was i'm
here as an empathetic person i'm i'm
here as an empathetic person who wants
you to do everything i want you to do
say galadriel from lord of the rings i
would be a queen not a queen of darkness
but a queen of power
it starts off all night you're like
being nice to frodo and then also she's
like
queen
it's it's quite wonderful then they get
to old man biden yelling at clouds
but he's very passionate he was very
angry because the only animating feature
of joe biden really deep down the only
reason he is president is because he is
not donald trump that is the only reason
that he is president of the united
states and it's the only thing that
animates him i mean this is perfectly
obvious by the way he has said in open
interviews that he doesn't know if he's
going to run for president in 2024 he
says i think i will but i'm a big
believer in inflate and sometimes health
and you know and then david muir from
abc news is like what if trump runs like
well then you're tempting me you're
dying joker grin you're chanting me
right because the only thing that made
joe biden president was running against
donald trump he'll get to that in just
one moment first
let's say that you're an uncle to a
young kid that kid has been put in your
care and the kid is he's a good kid but
he's kind of wayward and he for some
reason he lately he's been undergoing
some sort of changes kind of physical
mental changes you're not sure what what
the deal is and one day you just you you
see him running after a criminal on the
street and the criminal runs up to you
and shoots you as you lie bleeding on
the street you look up at him you say
peter parker i should have bought life
insurance from policy genius because now
aunt may is just she's living in this
derelict old house well you don't have
to be like uncle ben you should have
gone over to policygenius.com head on
over to policygenius.com shapiro answer
a few questions about yourself in
minutes you can work out how much life
insurance coverage you need compare
personalized quotes to find your best
price you could save 50 or more on life
insurance by comparing quotes with
policy genius their license experts help
you understand your options and apply
for a policy the policy genius team
works for you not the insurance
companies you can trust them to offer
unbiased help and advocate with you
every step until you are covered policy
genius doesn't add on extra fees they
don't sell your information to third
parties head on over to policygenius.com
shapiro to get your free life insurance
quotes see how much you could save today
policygenius.com
shapiro okay so now we get to old man
biden yelling at clouds so
president biden takes to the podium
and most of this speech was just about
how bad trump is trump is very bad and
bad is trump and trump is bad okay but
that would not in
that would not in any
real way
be about january 6th because january 6
was about more than trump
right the activities that trump involved
himself in from november 4th to january
6th in which he denied the election in
which he suggested that the election was
completely the result of electoral fraud
that he had outright won more votes in
places like arizona georgia pennsylvania
michigan wisconsin
all of that was bad behavior that was
malfeasance it was not true
there was certainly some electoral fraud
because in a country with 155 million
voters there will be some electoral
fraud there was certainly corruption
when it came to some of the election
rules many states embrace rules that
were completely out of the box
originally because of covid but then as
it became clear that you could vote
without really risking your own health
it was not because of covet anymore so
when pennsylvania decided to overrule
its own constitution and simply put in
place a bunch of full-scale absentee
balloting
well that was a violation of law even if
the pennsylvania supreme court didn't
call it that way but
trump had every opportunity to challenge
that stuff in court he brought some 80
lawsuits i believe all but one ended up
being being struck down even the one
that wasn't struck down ended up being
overruled at a certain point he didn't
even make most of the allegations in
court that he made publicly but that's
not what biden is talking about what
biden is saying is that trump is
responsible for the destruction of
democracy
that that's that's on trump and it's and
mostly it's on everyone who disagrees
with joe biden you have to give joe
biden your full faith because he's
standing in the in the face of a a
full-scale assault on democracy that
continues to this very day because
here's the thing trump left office he's
no longer president
january 6th happened over a year ago
so the the the notion that that we are
all just waiting for joe biden to save
us from the grave threat of trump
i'm not sure who he's talking to other
than his base but being very very angry
about trump and then suggesting the
entire republican party is is going to
overthrow elections when it was the
republican party by the way that
certified the 2020 election remember
never forget it was mike pence who
certified the election that was that was
the guy who was the the incumbent vice
president it was senator mitch mcconnell
who oversaw the certification of
election results
it was a republican secretary of state
like brad raffensberger in georgia and
republican governors in arizona
it was a bunch of republican state
legislatures that certified these votes
and so we were not close to a coup we
were not close to an overthrow of
american democracy and so that kind of
gives the lie to everything that biden
is saying but biden has to gin up the
outrage he has to gin up the rage
because if he does not gin that stuff up
he's got nothing it is all january 6th
or bust for joe biden at this point he's
riding at 40 percent in the approval
ratings and 2022 is going to hit him
like a tsunami
so he steps up to the microphone and he
gets animated for the first time in his
presidency this is the first time he has
looked alive for at least a year
joe biden has been wandering around in a
stupefied zombie state as though under
the influence of opiates for nearly his
entire presidency he looks as though
he's constantly falling asleep but not
yesterday yesterday he actually looked
mildly alive it was it was strange he
kind of looked like he was the only time
that joe biden looks alive is when he
can yell about trump
so that's what he did yesterday and
you're all supposed to give him power
and pretend that he's not a bad
president because trump
so he began by by suggesting the that
the the january 6th was a grave assault
on democracy that nearly ended the
230-odd year experiment of the united
states which of course is ridiculous and
silly on his face
state the obvious
one year ago today
in this sacred place
democracy
was attacked
simply attacked
the will of the people was under assault
the constitution our constitution
faced
the gravest of threats well wait so the
gravest of threat was just to get this
straight a couple of hundred idiots
trespassing yelling breaking windows and
committing criminal acts against police
officers in the capital being cleared
out within three hours and then
the certification taking place
if our honestly if our constitution and
our liberty is that fragile then the
problem ain't donald trump the problem
is her institutions but here's the thing
it isn't that fragile isn't remotely
close to that fragile
there are a bunch of people in the oval
office who are passing around dumb memos
about what mike pence could do to stop
the election none of it was true and so
none of it was effectuated
end of story this was not a grave threat
to democracy you know there are other
countries where there are grave threats
to democracy those threats usually
include things like disbanding the
legislature by the executive branch
those things usually include military
occupations of capitals those things
usually include laws passed by
legislatures that grants ultimate power
to the executive branch essentially
removing the legislature from the
purview of the entire process
those things include
stacking the supreme court or getting
rid of the supreme court look at
countries all over the world where
democracy has fallen it includes actual
changes to institutions it does not
include
a couple of hundred rowdies going into a
place and being cleared out by the cops
that's called like
most
most political events
that are bad in the united states like
that's been happening for for quite a
while okay so that again that is not to
downplay the evils of january 6th or the
people committed crimes that is not to
downplay trump's lies from november 4th
to january 6th and some of the stuff
that he says today what it is to say is
that if you are saying that we were like
this far away from democracy falling in
the united states on january 6 i don't
know what to tell you you're a
you're stupid if you actually believe
that we are this close to democracy
falling completely on january
6th that you're a motivated believer or
an idiot you want to believe it or you
you're just dumb and you're taken in
we'll get to more from angry joe biden
animated joe biden in just one second
first let's talk about saving gas so
here's the reality your gas prices are
extremely high right now and hell you
spend a lot of money on gas anyway so
why exactly would you not go out to the
app store and get the free get upside
app my listeners are making up to 25
cents for every gallon of gas every time
they fill up you can download the free
get upside app in the app store or
google play right now use promo code
shapiro get a bonus 25 cents per gallon
on your first fill up that's up to 50
cents cash back do not pay full price at
the pump anymore get cash back using get
upside just download the app for free
use promo code shapiro to get up to 50
cents per gallon cash back on your very
first tank of gas some people who drive
a lot are making as much as two to three
hundred bucks a month in cash back there
is no catch the cash back gets added
directly to your account you can cash
out anytime to your bank account paypal
or an egift card for amazon and other
brands just download that free get
upside app use promo code shapiro get up
to 50 cents per gallon cashback on your
very first tank of gas that is promo
code shapiro when you go to the app
store get that free get upside app and
once again use promo code shapiro to get
up to 50 cents per gallon cash back on
your very first tank of gas alrighty so
joe biden steps to the lectern and he
talks about january 6th in very colorful
language some of which actually is is
false
or very least wildly exaggerated so here
he is talking about using your
imagination use your imagination folks
put yourself back on january 6th the
most important day in american history
close your eyes
go back to that day
what do you see
rioters rampaging
waving for the first time inside this
capitol
confederate flag that symbolized the
cause to destroy america
to rip us apart
even during the civil war that never
ever happened
but it happened here
in 2021 um so uh is he now suggesting
that
this was like worse than the civil war
there was a confederate flag in the
capitol building that never even
happened during the civil war well i
mean six hundred thousand americans did
die during the civil war so there was
that
and there was a massive battlefront that
ranged all the way
from
like texas
to washington dc so i mean i feel like
that was worse
but there was one carrying a
confederate flag in the capitol building
so i guess we're all supposed to
i guess that's the same sort of by the
way i love that he's like the the
capital you know the fact that there was
a confederate flag in the in the capitol
building that's that's never happened
even the civil war until five seconds
ago there was a statue of jefferson
davis in statuary hall where he is
speaking right now they removed it last
year
they removed in 2021.
right so um what
okay but but it's ju
that idiot we're waving waving the
confederate flag and cat in in
statuary hall well that means that that
the republic was this close to falling
because of helmet-horned guy because of
the wagnerian opera helmet guy
okay then he talks about the assault on
police officers and this kind of stuff
really gets my goat it really does you
can't spend
years literally years ripping on the
police's systemically racist enforcers
of the patriarchal institutions of the
united states
seeking to criminalize blackness the new
jim crows michelle alexander puts you
can't you can't say that police all
across the country
are emissaries of evil but then when it
suits your purposes they become heroes
again that's not the way any of that
crap works
the people who saw police officers
across the board should go to jail i
feel that way democrats don't
but here is here is joe biden
all of a sudden a police a friend of the
police
a crowd that professes their love for
law enforcement assaulted those police
officers
dragged them sprayed them stomped on
them
over 140 police officers were injured
can you muster this kind of rage for the
2000 police officers plus who were
injured during the black lives matter
riots of 2020 nope can you muster any of
that outrage for the police officers who
have been wrongly castigated by the
press over the course of the last seven
years because remember this really
started in 2014 with the ferguson riots
that's really when this started so going
back years and years and years the
democrats have been wildly anti-police
the the attempt now to retcon this into
oh we found one event where some people
who were allied with the right or felt
they were on the right where those
people assaulted police officers
therefore the police are now good they
bring forth the hero police officers it
really is an astonishing thing it is
like they just assume that we have no
no common sense or memory that we have
like the memory of a guppy
he continued along these lines
police were assaulted
lives at risk
the nation's capital under siege
this wasn't a group of tourists
this is an armed insurrection
okay so
for there to be an armed insurrection
usually people need to be armed
like this is a general rule they need to
be armed right in the term armed
insurrection there needs to be both an
insurrection and there needs to be
people who are armed so far as i'm aware
there's not been a single criminal
charge brought against people who
went into the capitol building it's not
to say that people weren't being violent
they were
armed usually implies that you are armed
with you know like an actual gun
armed with actual dangerous weaponry i'm
not aware that any of the charging
documents include a single firearm if
you're going to do an armed insurrection
typically you want to bring a firearm
because that's usually the weapon you
used in an armed insurrection second an
insurrection usually requires an element
of planning like if you're going to plan
an insurrection you actually have to
plan the insurrection typically it's not
just a bunch of people who get pissed
off and and go into a building and do
damage to it that's not an insurrection
okay so if you don't believe that black
lives matter burning storefronts in 2020
was an insurrection
then you really should not believe that
this was an insurrection so it was not
an armed insurrection it was a riot
there was a difference
okay riots are bad too people who riot
should go to jail armed insurrection is
a different thing when he says armed
insurrection what he means is that his
political enemies planned to violate the
government they plan to overthrow the
government of the united states
therefore i deserve all power wartime
power
this is something that democrats
routinely invoke war time wait there's a
war on poverty war on climate change
there's a war on whatever they say their
war on income inequality war on racism
and there's always a war why why do
democrats use that language i mean
aren't they pacifists the reason they
use the language of war is because
during wars you get to invoke wartime
powers and when you invoke authoritarian
powers you get to do whatever the hell
you want so when you say there's an
armed insurrection the natural
consequence of that is i need to be
empowered
in order to stomp out armed
insurrections i need wartime powers
which is exactly what joe biden wants i
have to point out one more thing with
regard to his rhetoric on police
officers it really is astonishing so a
little bit later on in the speech he
talks about mourning police officers
with jill in the capital rotunda and
here's what he had to say
jill and i
have more police officers in this
capital rotunda not once but twice
in the wake of january 6th wants to
honor officer brian siknik
who lost his life the day after the
attack and a second time to honor
officer billy evans
who lost his life defending his capital
as well this is such a peculiar move
that he's making right now this is such
a peculiar move so first officer brian
siegnik was not actually killed at the
january 6 riot right originally it was
reported that he was struck in the head
with a fire extinguisher and then he
died as a result of those injuries that
turned out not to be true it turns out
that he died as a result of presumably a
heart attack and he died after january
6. though that but put that one aside
because maybe you could make the medical
case that the stress of january 6 induce
the heart attack or something
the other guy he mentions there
the other guy he mentions there officer
billy evans
billy evans died as a result of an
attack at the capitol building that had
nothing to do with january 6th
so lumping the two of them in until
they're both results of january 6th is
crazy
do you remember the death of officer
billy evans i do it didn't become a
national issue because the way that the
media determined whether a crime story
is a national issue or not is by
determining whether the victimizer is a
person with whom they are politically
allied in some sense if the person is a
political enemy it's a national story if
the person could theoretically be
conceived of as a political ally it's
not a national story it's a local crime
story so sicknick's death was a national
story because january 6th was super
duper duper terrible but officer billy
evans death was not a national story the
reason by the way that joe biden went to
the rotunda for officer billy evans
specifically is because he wanted to
create the presumption that he was going
to do this for all officers it wasn't
just officers who died in the line of
duty with some relation to his political
enemies but lumping them in together
does precisely the reverse he's now
suggesting that billy evans died as a
result of january 6. that's not what
happened
here is the actual story billy evans
died
in april he died in april of 2021 when
he was struck by a car
who who exactly was driving that car
a 25 year old black
nationalist who espoused viewpoints
cons consummate with the nation of isla
the nation of islam
so um what
why is he being lumped into this what
does he have to do with january 6. he
doesn't he has nothing to do with
january 6 but if you can i mean they're
just willing to do anything they're
willing to lump anyone together they
have to do in order to in order to get
where they want to go it really is
pretty incredible okay in a second we're
going to get to joe biden's attack on
the republican party because again the
idea here is that january 6th is not a
criminal act carried out by people who
are now paying criminal penalties from
two from from a year ago no january 6th
is an ongoing trauma it's an ongoing
wound it's a bleeding abscess we'll get
to that in just one moment first
health insurance as we all know get very
expensive and very complicated very
quickly for a lot of people in the
united states concerned about the cost
of health insurance there aren't any
good options you either go out on your
own with no safety net or you pay
through the no's for a high deductible
plan that doesn't kick in until you've
spent thousands of bucks that is because
we have a broken health insurance system
in this country thanks to obamacare and
thanks to a lot of bad governmental
decisions over the course of decades
what if i told you you don't necessarily
need health insurance you deserve health
care freedom introducing crowd health
crowd health is not health insurance
it's a community of people who care
about their health health care freedom
and each other crowd health exists
because we're tired of overpaying for
broken healthcare it introduces
consumerism into the market letting you
navigate the care you need
without the burdens of government
bureaucracy you're free to get the care
you need and when big expenses come the
community crowdfunds the bill on your
behalf joining crowdhealth gives you
your healthcare freedom back while
saving you thousands of bucks every year
why crowdhealth well it is flexible
membership is a monthly subscription
there's no limiting enrollment period or
messy contracts there's no limiting
doctor networks you can see the
providers you want for the care you need
it's simple you can use crowdhealth's
digital tools to find plan and pay for
the care that you need press a button to
receive virtual care anytime anywhere
five minutes to sign up 30 seconds to
find a great doctor 15 seconds to scan
and submit a bill for crowdfunding
crowdhealth is able to offer amazing
prices because of its community of
health conscious members crowded health
is not health insurance it's a
community-powered alternative give it a
look terms and conditions may apply
check them out today crowdhealth
alrighty so
then joe biden got to his real point his
real point is that everyone who
disagrees with him politically is
complicit in january 6th so he says sure
there are some courageous men and women
in the republican party who've stood up
to donald trump and here's liz cheney
and here's dick cheney dick cheney
showed up at the capitol building
yesterday to support his daughter liz
and suddenly democrats love him okay
whenever you are being
treated with quote-unquote strange new
respect
you should have a second thought you
might think hmm why are all these people
who hate everything about they literally
made a movie about the evils of dick
cheney called vice by adam mckay who is
one of the most overrated filmmakers in
hollywood
dick cheney was darth vader he was the
bugaboo of the left and suddenly he's a
hero of the republic amazing how that
works almost as though they will use
whatever object is available to clock
whoever is in power now okay so here was
here was joe biden trying to lump in the
entire republican party not just with
trump but more broadly with january 6th
well some courageous men and women in
the republican party are standing
against it
trying to uphold the principle of that
party
too many others are transforming that
party into something else
they seem no longer to want to be the
party
the party of lincoln
eisenhower reagan the bushes okay can we
stop pretending that these people loved
the party of lincoln reagan eisenhower
and the bushes
they hated all those people i mean
george w bush was bush hitler george w
bush was an illegitimate president
according to the democrats because of
2000. george w bush was a war monger who
led us into a bush lied people died
right i mean
it is so tiresome it is so tiresome to
hear democrats proclaim the virtues of
people they hated until 30 seconds ago
when those people became much more
convenient to them and i will say
i'll say this about about dick cheney or
the bushes
i have a lot of fondness for some of
these people from the bush
administration i do because i remember
defending a lot of their actions during
the bush administration okay but but if
you spend your entire post-political
career saying nothing when democrats run
roughshod across everything that you
held dear and then you can only be found
speak to a camera as soon as something
bad happens from the republican side of
the aisle i have some questions
consistency folks a little bit of
consistency if you couldn't be found
anywhere during the black lives matter
riots of 2020 if you couldn't be found
anywhere during the russia collusion
stuff if you couldn't be found anywhere
while the democrats are trying to ram
through authoritarian coveted measures
you can't be found anywhere defending
many of the people who supported you but
you can be dredged up in order to do a
january 6th
extravaganza on behalf of nancy pelosi
in the cast of hamilton i have some
questions about the people you're
hanging out with in your priorities
really i may agree with some of the
stuff they even say but i have some real
questions about your sense of of
loyalty to the people who got you where
you are
okay jo put that aside joe biden
continues and then he gets into again
the double standards here are just they
are mind-boggling and they're maddening
they're maddening so joe biden starts
talking about the the higher standards
of america that he supposedly hold and
every line here it's like buy yourself a
mirror joe please for the love of god
look in a mirror get your party a damned
mirror sir here we go
are we going to be a nation that accepts
political violence as a norm
are we going to be a nation
will we allow partisan election
officials to overturn
the legally expressed will of the people
are going to be a nation that lives not
by the light of the truth
but in the shadow
of lies
we cannot allow ourselves to be that
kind of nation okay so i have many many
many questions for the democratic party
are we going to be a nation that accepts
political violence as a norm says joe
biden oh i don't know did your vice
president literally attempt to bail out
rioters a year ago
i
i feel like that happened because i was
there that was a year and a half ago
where were you during the black lives
matter riots joe biden
accepts political violence as a norm
and honest to god these people it's
unbelievable
they just they just are going to 1984
your memories out of existence they're
just going to memory whole all this crap
anything bad that happened on there
until now until january 6 did you know
there'd been no acceptance of political
violence as a norm did you know that
that didn't exist it was only trump it
wasn't maxine waters saying you should
get up in people's faces or calling the
la riots the la uprising in 1993 1994
it wasn't democrats poo pooing massive
rioting across the country in 2020
saying it was mostly peaceful
it wasn't democrats ignoring the
violence in portland that went on for
months and months and months and when
donald trump sent federal troops in to
try and stop that by protecting federal
buildings they called him a fascist
i remember that stuff because i'm not an
idiot i have a functional brain but some
of these people apparently think that
they can just get away with saying that
the only people who have normal
political violence are people on the
right it's crazy
and it's wild and then he said are we
gonna be a nation where we allow
partisan election officials to overturn
the legally expressed will of i don't
know didn't you guys claim that stacey
abrams was still the governor of georgia
aren't you currently engaged in
redistricting that is far more
beneficial to democrats than republican
redistricting has been to republicans
are we going to be a nation that lives
not by the light of truth but in the
shadow of lies okay i i have no words
for this
from the biden administration which lies
as a matter of routine
they do it over
afghanistan was a was a months-long lie
from don't worry the government won't
collapse it'll be fine to we always knew
the government was going to collapse and
it'll still be fine too we're not
allying in any way with like to al qaeda
has gone from the country so don't worry
our soldiers are safe so don't worry
we're evacuating people in the most
brilliant evacuation since dunkirk
all they do is lie
shadow of lies my ass
we can't allow ourselves to be that kind
of nation we i'm sorry like that
we
too late
you made it happen joe biden you've been
in office since 1831
and then he gets to the same point as
kamal harris just takes him longer to
get there his new point is you have to
let us completely rewrite election law
in the united states in order to save
democracy we have to we have to wreck
democracy by federalizing all election
procedure under the auspices of people
joe biden likes
right now
in state after state
new laws are being written
not to protect the vote
but to deny it
not only to suppress the vote but to
subvert it
not to strengthen or protect our
democracy
but because the former president lost
instead of looking at the election
results from 2020 and saying
they need new ideas or better ideas to
win more votes
the former president
and his supporters have decided the only
way for them to win
is to suppress your vote
and subvert our elections
it's wrong
it's undemocratic
and frankly it's unamerican okay i mean
this is the same shtick that this
schmuck was trotting out with regard to
the georgia law which he called a new
form of jim crow so no i don't believe
you i also don't believe that you care
very much about election integrity when
you spend literally a year talking about
how all of the emergency protocols taken
during covid ought to be made the new
normal we ought to be sending absentee
ballots to every household in the nation
we ought to be having democratic
employees engaged in ballot harvesting
going door to door to democratic
registered voters and picking up their
ballots we have to get rid of voter id
everywhere across the country we have to
federalize all election procedures that
states have no say in it whatsoever
you know i don't believe that you care
about election integrity i believe that
you want to rig the rules
because you do
yeah i mean the democrats won't even get
together with the republicans to reform
the electoral account act if you are
worried about people quote-unquote
stealing federal elections the electoral
count act which led to the vagary of
some people wrongly believing that the
vice president and that the congress had
the ability to throw out state-certified
votes
if you believe that that's a problem
then there have been a bunch of
republicans including mainstream
right-wing republicans who have called
for a revision of the electoral account
act to clarify how that procedure works
you know what democrats have done they
said not enough we're not going to do it
we're not going to revise the electoral
contact because you don't care you don't
care what you really care about is
rigging the rules for yourself
he'll get to the conclusion of joe
biden's speech in just one moment then
we'll get to some of the other democrats
sounding off on january 6th first 2020
it's gonna be a big year for a lot of
businesses we hope we pray some
industries are projected to grow even
more this year like fitness is expected
to explode home improvement renovation
decoration digital events and
conferences well listen if you own a
business and you're in one of these
growing industries and you're having
trouble finding employees which is like
everyone i've been talking to lately you
probably need to hire asap and you need
to go to ziprecruiter to make it happen
right now you can try it for free at
zippercrew.com dailywire ziprecruiter
uses powerful technology to find and
match the right candidates up with your
job then it proactively presents these
candidates to you you can easily review
these recommended candidates and invite
your top choices to apply for your job
that encourages them to apply faster no
wonder zip recruit is the number one
rated hiring site in the united states
based on g2 ratings zip recruiters
technology is so effective that four out
of five employers who post unzip
recruiter get a quality candidate within
the very first day right now you can try
ziprecruiter for free at this exclusive
web address ziprecruiter.com
dailywire that's ziprecruiter.com
[Music]
w i r d-a-i-l-y-w-i-r-e zip recruiter
dot com
daily wire zipper crew is indeed the
smartest way to hire alright we'll get
to more in just one second first is that
glorious time of the week when i give a
shout out to a daily ware member today
the lucky person is jonathan rivera on
instagram who understands proper equine
care in this picture jonathan is
standing next to a handsome steed that
appears to be attempting a swig from the
world's greatest beverage vessel the
caption reads you can lead a horse to
water but you can't make a drink unless
it is the sweet tears from a superior
drinking vessel after a night of patrol
it's nice to know i can still get the
caffeine i need to handle a
four-year-old thoroughbred like my buddy
liam at close to a thousand pounds he's
quite literally ben's biggest fan
hashtag left his tears tumbler that is
awesome and better than yellowstone glad
to know you're both out there keeping
the jersey streets safe thanks for the
pick and thanks for being a daily wire
member also today it is a big day for
the daily wear it's a huge day for
america the supreme court is currently
like as of right now hearing oral
arguments on joe biden's
unconstitutional authoritarian vax
mandate okay right now we have over a
million signatures on our do not comply
petition but today we want to boost that
like today's a great day to boost it
head on over to dailywear.com do not
comply right now we're counting on you
to help us put a stop to this absolutely
disgusting tyrannical federal overage go
check them out right now you're
listening to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
alrighty so finally joe biden concludes
with his statement he is going to stand
at the door of democracy and block it
from the dagger that's there
you're going to have to pry this
democracy for my gold lifeless
joe biden
believe me
no i know how difficult democracy is i
don't believe you
i'm crystal clear
about the threats that america faces
but i also know
that our darkest days
can lead to light and hope
from the death and destruction as the
vice president referenced in pearl
harbor
can the triumph over the forces of
fascism from the brutality of bloody
sunday
on the edmond pettis bridge
came historic voting rights legislation
so now let's step up
write the next chapter in american
history
where january 6 marks not the end of
democracy
but the beginning of a renaissance of
liberty and fair play
i did not seek this fight
brought to this capital one year ago
today
but i will not shrink from it either
i will stand in this breach
i will defend this nation
not allow no one to place a dagger at
the throat of democracy
um okay so he's really comparing january
6 to the edmund pettus bridge you mean
you know like a protest that the literal
authorities
sicked dogs on people who were
protesting a century of jim crow
that's the same thing as january 6th
or comparing it to pearl harbor because
it's just like pearl harbor when 2 300
americans died
or alternatively you just want what you
want and this is your excuse my favorite
part of this is that joe biden was asked
after his ridiculous speech about why he
had not used donald trump's name right
he kept avoiding trump's name he kept
saying the former president this and the
former president that his answer is just
it's one for the ages here was joe
biden's answer to that question
it's not about whether i'm president or
she's vice president
it's about the system and about somebody
who decides to put
himself above everything
and
so
but i did not want to turn it into
a contemporary
political battle
between me and the president it's way
beyond that he didn't want to turn it
into a contemporary political battle
really that that is literally the only
thing that they are doing yesterday
that's the whole point of the exercise
is to turn it into a contemporary
political battle that's why you do a
memorial for january 6th that's why you
do all these commemorative editions cnn
specials and all of this kind of stuff
that's why you do it the whole point of
it is this you know what the real point
of this is the real point is that
non-farm job estimates came in 200 000
jobs below what they were supposed to
this month that's the real story
okay the actual democratic the december
jobs report came in adding 199 000 jobs
against expectations of 422 000 jobs
that's the real story under joe biden
not that he's standing preventing the
dagger from entering the throat of
democracy or some such self-serving bull
bleep alrighty we'll be back here later
today with an additional hour of content
first you cannot forget to end your week
by tuning in to the andrew clavin show
drew's shows every friday he's got an
exciting evening planned for you as
always head on over to dailywire.com 7
p.m eastern 6 p.m central tune in i'm
ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feldt executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover and our production manager
is pavo wydowski associate producer
bradford carrington editing is by adam's
high event audio is mixed by mike
coromina hair and makeup is by fabiola
christina production assistant jessica
crand the ben shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire
2022.
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me andrew clavin